Assalamu alaykum. My name is Bush
Muhammad Sira and I'm a student. My
question for you is how do we decrease
Islamophobia in the west especially with
how the west has a negative view on
Islam? We ask a question how do we deal
with Islamophobia in the western world?
And toward the end of my speech I know I
have to cut my speech short. We were
supposed to be for one and a half hour
because the organizers did not follow
the sequence and they kept on
interjecting with things not not there
in the program. I came late and I had to
cut my speech by 20 minutes
short. As I said the most important
today the most powerful weapon is the
media. It can convert black into white
day into night hero into a vanilla into
hero. So we have to utilize the media
for dispelling the misconception about
Islam and I give the example of peace
TV. One is the satellite media, then you
have the print media, then you have the
newspaper media, then you have the
social media, you have the Facebook, you
have Instagram, you have YouTube and
whatever you can do, number one spread
the correct teachings of Islam. Number
two, reply to the
misconception. Very important. I said
second point also is that have
conferences which are professional
conferences that people would like to
attend. Not only Muslims then
non-Muslims also come. Here we have
non-Muslims mashallah have conferences
of
quality. Get
speakers which can dispel the myth
against Islam and make it publicly
available.
record it, put it on the social media.
So here though the audience will be
about 10 to 20,000 but on the satellite
millions are watching and we're using
good camera so that even after I die I
don't know how long will I live but the
recording can be for 100 years 100 years
other recording other camera 2 three
years gone 3 years gone I want sabi jar
so whatever way the west malign Islam
you have to reply
accordingly I have giving a talk on
misconceptions about Islam that's in
Mombasa the 20 common questions you have
to reply with reason logic and science.
So when you reply see to it you use the
strategy of the
Quran come to common terms as we ascend
you and when you're doing dawa you may
talk about anything no problem you can
talk start with science talk with
literature but your main aim should be
removing the shik from the lives of the
non-Muslim your main aim should be
Allahill that we worship none but
one that that we associate a partner of
the
team that we erect not among ourselves
lords and other than Allah if then they
turn
back that we are Muslims bowing to Allah
what we have to do is we have to be good
examples good examples of
Muslim remove the misconception and we
should interact with the
non-Muslim and We should see to it that
we whatever the media is bombarding
misconceptions regarding Islam, we have
to clarify it with reason, logic and
science. Hope that answers the question.